[Music]
to go with the steamed pudding
we're making a super simple whiskey
cream start by whisking 150 milliliters
of double cream and and whisk lovely I
always get the hard jobs Gordon I'm just
thinking those bingo wings mother I mean
bingo hands eyes down yes all right
thank you now little splash of whiskey
little drop okay lovely and then finally
a little bit Irish cream doesn't most of
their mum just in case we have plus one
thirty seconds time thank you
some air when you hit the kitchen okay
man lovely put the whiskey cream in the
fridge until you're ready to serve that
should be ready hopefully of course when
the pudding is finished steaming turn it
out onto a plate does the trick Wow does
this boost it a little bit on the sides
thank you
nice winners crossed this pudding is
another dish you can make in advance
simply reheat by steaming again oops
today they so happy you go to Shu Shu
[Music]
nobody's man smells amazing to film over
pudding piece and whiskey light at the
table and pour over how to give your
roast potatoes a delicious kick
yeah chili flake just put away heat in
there and the secret is making Brussels
sprouts and tastes extraordinary so
we've managed to turn a sort of playing
James sprouts into something delicious